¿Para qué molestarse?
El resultado está amañado.
Mi voto no contará.
Las opciones son pésimas.
Votar es para tontos.
Tal vez hayas pensado algunas de estas cosas.
Tal vez incluso las has dicho.
Y si es así, no estarías solo, y no estarías del todo mal.
El juego de la política pública actual está manipulado de muchas maneras.
Sino, ¿cómo es que más de la mitad de los recortes de impuestos federales
fluyen hasta el 5% más rico de los estadounidenses?
Y nuestras opciones de hecho a menudo son terribles.
Para muchas personas en todo el espectro político,
la prueba A es la elección presidencial de 2016.
Pero, en cualquier año, pueden revisar la boleta de votación
y encontrarán muchas razones para desmotivarse.
Pero a pesar de todo esto, todavía creo que votar importa.
Y por descabellado que suene
creo que podemos revivir la alegría de votar.
Hoy, quiero hablar sobre cómo podemos hacer eso y por qué.
En algún momento en la historia estadounidense votar era muy divertido,
cuando era mucho más que un simple deber pesado presentarse en las urnas.
Ese momento se conoce como "la mayor parte de la historia de Estados Unidos".
De la revolución a la era de los derechos civiles,
los Estados Unidos tenía una cultura participativa
vibrante y robusta sobre votar.
Había teatro en las calles, debates abiertos, fiesta y banquetes,
desfiles y hogueras.
Durante el siglo XX, los inmigrantes y las maquinarias políticas urbanas
ayudaron a impulsar esta cultura de la votación.
Esa cultura creció con cada ola sucesiva de nuevos votantes.
Durante la reconstrucción, con los nuevos votantes negros,
los nuevos ciudadanos negros,
comenzaron a ejercer su poder,
celebraban en desfiles jubilares
que unían la emancipación a su recién descubierto derecho al voto.
Unas décadas más tarde, las sufragistas
llevaron un espíritu de teatralidad a la lucha,
marchando juntas vestidas de blanco mientras reclamaban su derecho.
Y el movimiento de los derechos civiles,
que aspiraba cumplir la promesa de igualdad entre los ciudadanos
que Jim Crow traicionó,
ponía el derecho de voto como algo central.
Del verano de la libertad a la marcha en Selma,
esa generación de activistas sabía que votar importaba,
y sabía que la vigilancia y el desempeño del poder
eran la llave para poder reclamar el poder.
Pero ha pasado más de medio siglo desde la ley de derecho al voto y Selma,
y en las décadas que siguieron,
esta cultura de la votación
ha casi desaparecido.
La televisión la ha matado
y también el internet.
El sofá reemplazó a las plazas.
Las pantallas convierten a los ciudadanos en espectadores.
Y aunque es agradable compartir memes políticos en las redes sociales,
es una ciudadanía muy discreta.
Es lo que el sociólogo Sherry Turkle llama "estar juntos y solos".
Lo que necesitamos hoy
es una cultura electoral donde estemos juntos juntos,
en persona,
en formas fuertes y apasionadas,
para que en lugar de ser como "coma frutas y verduras" o "cumpla"
el voto pueda sentirse más como "únete al club"
o, mejor aún, "únete a la fiesta".
Imagina si tuviéramos, en todo el país en este momento,
en lugares locales en todo el país,
un esfuerzo concertado para revivir los encuentros cara a cara
para unirse y elegir:
espectáculos al aire libre donde se burlen de los candidatos y sus causas
y se valore un estilo satírico;
discursos improvisados de los ciudadanos;
debates públicos celebrados en bares;
calles llenas de arte político y carteles hechos a mano y murales;
batallas de bandas que compiten por representar a sus candidatos.
Todo esto te puede sonar un poco del siglo XVIII
pero en realidad, no tiene porqué ser más del siglo XVIII
que, digamos, el musical de Broadway Hamilton,
puede ser vibrante y contemporáneo.
Y el hecho es que en todo el mundo,
hoy en día, millones de personas votan así.
En la India, las elecciones son coloridas, asuntos comunales.
En Brasil, el día de las elecciones es una fiesta carnavalesca.
En Taiwán y Hong Kong hay un espectáculo,
un espectáculo impresionante,
de teatro de la calle por las elecciones.
Te puedes preguntar, bueno, aquí en EE.UU., ¿quién tiene tiempo para eso?
Y te diría
que el estadounidense promedio ve cinco horas de televisión al día.
Te puedes preguntar, ¿quién tiene la motivación?
Y te voy a decir,
cualquier ciudadano que quiera que lo vean y lo oigan
no como un apoyo, no como un tema de conversación,
sino como un participante, un creador.
Pues bien, ¿cómo podemos hacer que esto suceda?
Simplemente haciendo que suceda.
Es por eso que un grupo de colegas y yo
hemos puesto en marcha un nuevo proyecto llamado "La alegría de votar".
En cuatro ciudades de los Estados Unidos,
Filadelfia, Miami,
Akron, Ohio, y Wichita, Kansas,
hemos reunido a artistas y activistas,
educadores, políticos amigos, vecinos, ciudadanos comunes
para unirse y crear proyectos
que pueden fomentar esta cultura de la votación de manera local.
En Miami, eso significa fiesta toda la noche con DJs de moda
donde la única manera de entrar es mostrar que estás empadronado.
En Akron hay obras políticas
que se realizan en la plataforma de un camión
que se mueve de un barrio a otro.
En Filadelfia,
hay una casería del tesoro temático de la votación en la parte colonial antigua.
Y en Wichita, se trata de hacer mixtapes y grafitis en directo
en el extremo norte para promover la votación.
Hay 20 de estos proyectos,
y son notables por su belleza y diversidad
y están cambiando a la gente.
Déjenme decirles acerca de un par de ellos.
En Miami, encargamos a
un joven artista llamado Atómico, que creara unas imágenes vivas y vibrantes
para una nueva serie de calcomanías "Yo Voté".
Pero la cosa es que Atómico nunca había votado.
Ni siquiera estaba empadronado.
Entonces mientras creaba estas obras de arte para las calcomanías
también empezó a no sentirse intimidado por la política.
Se empadronó,
se informó acerca de la próxima elección primaria,
y el día de elección ahí estaba no solo para repartir calcomanías
sino para conversar con los votantes y animar a la gente a votar
y hablar de las elecciones con los transeúntes.
En Akron, una compañía de teatro llamada "Estética Errante"
montó obras sobre camionetas.
Y, para ello, hacen una convocatoria abierta al público
pidiendo discursos, monólogos, diálogos, poemas,
fragmentos que puedan leerse en voz alta
e integrarse en una actuación.
Tienen docenas de contribuciones.
Una de ellas era un poema
escrito por nueve estudiantes en una clase de ESL,
todos ellos trabajadores migrantes hispanos
de la cercana Hartville, Ohio.
Quiero leerles este poema.
Se llama "La alegría de votar".
"Me gustaría votar por primera vez
porque las cosas están cambiando para los hispanos.
Yo solía tener miedo a los fantasmas.
Ahora tengo miedo de la gente.
Hay más violencia y racismo.
Votar puede cambiar esto.
El muro de la frontera no es nada.
Es solo una pared.
El muro de la vergüenza es algo.
Es muy importante votar
para poder tirar ese muro de la vergüenza.
Tengo la pasión en mi corazón.
Votar me da una voz y poder.
Puedo levantarme y hacer algo".
"La alegría de votar" no se trata solo de alegría.
Es sobre esta pasión.
Se trata de sentir y creer
y que no es solo el trabajo de nuestra organización.
A lo largo de todo este país, en este momento,
inmigrantes, jóvenes, veteranos, personas de orígenes diversos
se unen para crear este tipo de actividades apasionadas, alegres
en torno a las elecciones,
en estados rojos y azules, en comunidades urbanas y rurales,
personas de cualquier filiación política.
Lo que tienen en común es simplemente esto:
su trabajo se desarrolla localmente.
Porque, toda ciudadanía es local.
Cuando la política es solo una elección presidencial,
gritamos y gritamos a las pantallas y luego nos derrumbamos, exhaustos.
Pero cuando la política es sobre nosotros
y nuestros vecinos y otras personas de nuestra comunidad
que se unen para crear una experiencia colectiva de voz e imaginación,
entonces empezamos a recordar que importa.
Empezamos a recordar que esta es la base del autogobierno.
Lo que me lleva de vuelta a donde empecé.
¿Para qué molestarse?
Hay una manera de responder a esta pregunta.
El voto importa porque es un acto auto cumplido de creer.
Se alimenta del espíritu de interés mutuo que
hace que cualquier sociedad prospere.
Cuando votamos, incluso si lo hacemos enojados,
somos parte de un salto de fe creativo y colectivo.
La votación nos ayuda a generar el poder que nos gustaría tener.
No es casualidad que la democracia y el teatro
surgieran en la misma época en la antigua Atenas.
Ambos llevan a la persona de lo privado a lo público.
Ambos crean grandes experiencias comunes de un ritual compartido.
Ambos dan vida a la imaginación
en formas que nos recuerdan que todos nuestras relaciones al final
se imaginan y se pueden reimaginar.
Este momento, ahora,
cuando pensamos en el significado de imaginación,
es tan fundamentalmente importante,
y nuestra habilidad de tomar ese espíritu
y entender que
hay algo más grande,
no es solo una cuestión de conocimientos técnicos.
No es solo una cuestión de tener el tiempo o saber hacerlo.
Es una cuestión de espíritu.
Pero voy dar una respuesta a "¿para qué molestarse?"
un poco menos espiritual y un poco más enfocada.
¿Para qué molestarse en votar?
Por que no hay no votantes.
No votar es votar,
por todo a lo que se oponen y detestan.
No votar puede entenderse
como un acto de resistencia de principios pasiva
pero en realidad no votar
entrega activamente el poder
a aquellos cuyos intereses están en contra del suyo
y que estarían muy contentos de sacar ventaja de tu ausencia.
No votar es para los tontos.
Imagina dónde estaría este país
si todas las personas que en 2010 crearon el Tea Party
hubieran decidido que la política es demasiado complicada,
votar es demasiado complicado.
No hay posibilidad de que nuestros votos sumen nada.
No se silencian preventivamente a sí mismos.
Se presentan,
y al presentarse, cambiaron la política estadounidense.
Imagínese si todos los seguidores de Donald Trump y Bernie Sanders
hubíeran decidido no hacer añicos el status quo político
y destruir el marco de lo anteriormente posible
en la política estadounidense.
Lo hicieron mediante el voto.
Vivimos en un tiempo en este momento,
dividido, a menudo muy oscuro,
donde tanto en la izquierda y la derecha, se habla mucho de revolución
y la necesidad de la revolución para perturbar la democracia cotidiana.
Bueno, aquí está la cosa:
la democracia todos los días ya nos da una guía para la revolución.
En la elección presidencial de 2012,
los votantes jóvenes, los latinos,
estadounidenses de origen asiático, los de bajos ingresos,
todos se presentaron en al menos el 50%.
En las elecciones de 2014, la participación fue del 36%,
que fue la mínima en 70 años.
Y en su elección local promedio,
la participación se sitúa cerca del 20%.
Los invito a imaginar un 100%.
Imagínense un 100%.
Movilicen al 100%,
y durante la noche, tendremos la revolución.
Durante la noche, las prioridades de la política cambiarían drásticamente,
y todos los niveles de gobierno serían radicalmente más sensibles
a todas las personas.
¿Qué se necesita para movilizar al 100%?
Bueno, tenemos que enfrentar los esfuerzos
en todo el país en este momento
para que votar sea más difícil.
Pero al mismo tiempo,
tenemos que crear activamente una cultura positiva de la votación
a la que la gente quiera pertenecer,
ser parte y experimentar juntos.
Tenemos que crear propósitos.
Tenemos que hacerlo alegre.
Así que sí, vamos a tener la revolución,
una revolución del espíritu, de las ideas,
de la política y la participación,
una revolución contra el cinismo,
una revolución en contra del sentimiento de impotencia auto cumplido.
Votemos para que la revolución exista,
y ya que estamos en ello,
vamos a divertirnos un poco.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)